and you mentioned but by the way burning
man because of uh a psychedelic
experience is it the strawberries
or was it something else
what was what was the moment yeah that
was magical no it was dmt what
definitely
wasn't strawberries
no no i was um more potent
yeah i was like smoking dmt
and
like
i i saw like
if you in the midnight gospel there are
these bovine creatures that have like a
long neck and a lantern head
so like
i i saw one of those things and
um
and you know i thought it was funny and
like
ridiculous because you hear like all the
terence mckenna stories of
the self-transforming machine elfs or
all the
purple or the magenta goddess everyone
sees her i'm like
so this is what i get like
a [ __ ] cow with a lantern head like
that's where my brain is at and
interacting with this molecule so then
like
i look i look away
and again this is dmt so when i say look
away do i mean with my eyes shut i look
away our eyes open i look away i think i
shut
so it sounds weird to say look away but
however you want to put it that's what i
did
and i look back
and it's still there only now it's you
know because usually in like when you're
having those kinds of visions they go
away pretty quickly yeah this thing's
like moved
like shambled ahead maybe a few steps
just like a cow it's just like a cow
and then
that was when the
you know all the stories you hear about
it like going through some kind of tube
or
some kind of light tunnel like a water
slide made of light that's
increasingly familiar that's the wildest
part of it it's like oh i know this
place
not like i've seen this in like you know
on like bong stickers but like oh yeah
this is that place you go to you just
remember oh this place and then
it was like i was in some kind of uh
i don't know how to put it a chamber a
technological chamber some kind of
supercomputer some kind of nucleus that
was technological
and it was inviting there was an
invitation of like
comment like come deeper into come
deeper in
and uh
you can talk to whatever it is over
there you don't talk but there's a
communication
and i
communicated
but my friends
i don't i love my friends i guess i had
some sense in that moment that it would
mean
complete obliteration or
who knows what and the response that it
gave back was
you can always go back there
and that's when i opened my eyes i'm
back totally you know and ever since
then
that that's caused me to revise my
my thinking on reincarnation
the idea that you die and you start as a
baby and then live your life again it
goes right into what we were talking
about i you know that that maybe data
you know that the [ __ ] i saw in nitrous
i don't feel dumb that my epiphanies are
all related to drugs but not all of them
are a lot of them but this notion of
like oh
is it that we're
imprinting into the medium of time space
every
thing we do
and that that is a permanent imprint a
frame
that
upon
death
can be accessed in the same way we can
pull up
pictures on our phone or computers
and not only accessed but experienced
as
though in other words you could just
jump in
you're still gonna have your memories
it's gonna give you a
the illusion of having been a kid and
gotten to that frame but no you just
decided to go back there
nostalgia
whatever and
uh yeah you can jump around freely in
space and time yeah yeah you can go in
and out of time space but when you the
problem is when you go into time space
it's time
so it's gonna feel sticky it's going to
feel like you've been here forever
because you've dropped back onto the
track that nietzsche's talking about
and
i guess one of the qualities of dropping
into that frame is that you forget
your
higher dimensional identity
what happened to the cow with the
lantern
was that goodbye
he writes me letters sometimes
[Laughter]
never saw it again never never saw it
again but i put it in we put it in the
midnight gospel you know i like
pendleton was like
such a genius and he was he drew it for
me and then it just ended up as a part
of the show
you